you
starting in nineteen eighty nine which
was the year of the bicentennial of the
French Revolution and it's not
accidental that that was the year there
were there was an attempt by and by a
principal in one school in the outer
suburbs of France which is where large
immigrant populations live in kind of
ghetto like situations but this guy
decided that he was going to forbid
students to come to school in head
scarves he had political ambitions later
he ran for office and in fact of palm
I'm not sure if he won or not but he
certainly ran for office as a kind of
conservative in the consist of more
conservative side of things and he
forbid these girls to come to school
they refused to take their head scarves
off and a huge controversy ensued it's
no accident that it was the Bicentennial
because people were already very worried
because in election in 1988 in a
presidential election the right-wing
National Front party the phone us you
know had gained a made a considerable
showing they certainly hadn't won
anything they didn't get to go to the
second round but they got more votes
more larger percentage of the vote than
anybody thought they were going to get
and so there was a great deal of anxiety
in the parties to the left of his
extreme right party about what to do and
particularly the right-wing parties I
think decided they did not want to lose
votes that were seeming to go to the far
right and that involved since the far
right's platform was an anti-immigrant
platform that involved taking a stand on
the question of immigration and in
France immigrants don't mean people who
come from Portugal or Spain or Italy or
other countries of Europe or Western
Europe it means former Colonials from
North Africa and West Africa and so the
question of what to do about immigrants
how to stop immigration whether or not
they could ever be assimilated into
France whether assimilation had to
proceed by doing things like forbidding
headscarf signs of identification with
religious or cultural practices that
were not thought to be French that fed
into this into this controversy and I
think the 1989 part of it also the
Bicentennial the revolution meant that
there was a lot of talk about what the
Republic meant what republican
principles and ideals and theory meant
and this was the opportunity to draw the
line at what were and were not
acceptable practices for French citizens
lacie t the french version of secularism
was the the the issue and the argument
was that since schools were state-run
schools since there was a sharp
separation between church and state in
france since at least 1905 that you
could schools could not tolerate signs
of religious affiliation in france when
you pass a law or issue a decree you
cannot identify a particular group
France French republicanism is a
universalist so the law has to apply to
everybody when they did a law in gay
domestic partnerships in the nineteen
nineteen eighty nine eighty eight or in
innings nineteen ninety nine they
couldn't apply just to gay couples it
had to apply to two people cohabiting
together of whatever sex so it as many
heterosexual couples as homosexual
couples ended up getting these domestic
partnership arrangements so any law that
passes has to be apply across the board
and although these at first rules and
then in 2003-2004 the law was passed in
2004 the banning of head scarves and
public schools actually happened had to
apply to all signs of religious
affiliation for years boys with
yarmulkes seeks with turbans they're
very few seats with turbans but had been
allowed in the schools and basically the
teachers just turned a blind eye
historically in the 1880s when French
Universal compulsory education passes as
a way of inducting children into the
Republic and weaning them from the
influences of the priests kids were
allowed to wear anything and crosses and
the point was that the school
represented the place in which
republicanism happened to kids or
secular ideas were possible what
happened in then from 1989 on in these
series of controversies and then in the
law was that you had to come to school
basically already committed to
secularism so the role of the school as
the place which
ducted you into republican principles
was being transformed and now you had to
have those principles before you were
going to be allowed to come to school
that was a real transformation of what
the expectation of the role of the
school was in the education of children
right now we have the discussion of the
burqa the couple of months ago or at the
end of last year President Sarkozy
decided again clearly for political
reasons and clearly because of the fear
that the right was capturing more votes
than he wanted them to he and also i
think in response to obama's Cairo
speech remember Obama in his Cairo
speech talked about the fact that people
ought to be able to wear anything they
want when in public and when they go to
school and that was taken by the French
to be a direct criticism of the French
2004 law in response to all of that they
started looking around and discovered
when the conversation started they were
supposed to be 300 women in burkas and
now it's said to be about a thousand
it's a very tiny menurut Aryan
phenomenon a thousand in a population of
Muslims of about six million so you're
not we're not talking about threat I
don't think but he decided that he would
appoint or ask for a parliamentary he
actually Sarkozy didn't started it was a
communist deputy in the National
Assembly who called for a commission to
look into the advisability of women
being allowed to wear burqas anywhere in
public in France the Commission
recommended that well didn't recommend
anything exactly but said that it was a
complicated issue thought that it would
probably be a good idea to get rid of
them but didn't come down as hard as the
2003 Commission did recommending a law
banning head scarves in public schools
because the notion of interfering with
women in public would go against things
like the notion of a Liberty of
conscience which is a European Union
policy recommendation or requirement so
it was tricky but Sarkozy just in the
last couple of weeks has said that he
wants to ban the
in France which would mean these women
would have to stay at home all the time
because they have to wear this this gear
in whole day when they're in public it
would mean they couldn't walk in the
streets they couldn't go shopping in
stores they couldn't do anything that
would involve leaving the house the
argument there is interesting less about
lacy J because they can't really argue
that I mean you can argue I guess that
the streets are secular but they really
can't argue that that being that sort of
public the use of public space maybe
official government building schools
that kind of thing you can you can have
rules about who can come in and how
they're dressed but just the streets is
hard so now what they're saying that
this is has to do with equality of women
that the the burqa is a sign of women's
oppression that it is it goes against
what they're saying is a primordial and
fundamental principle of the French
Republic equality between women and men
what I find hypocritical is probably the
word is that visa is often the very same
guys who start not only Sarkozy but
Polly's politicians who are eager for
this to happen who when it comes to
talking about the Equality of women
women's access to politics in France did
everything they could to stop the
passage of a law in 2000 which was
passed and which requires equal access
equal representation on most ballots for
most elections of women and men but
these guys have found dozens of ways to
undermine the application of that law so
it's been very interesting to see how
the Equality of women is an issue when
we're talking about Muslims and thought
to be nothing of a problem at all when
it comes to be talking about France